みなさんこんにちは
2前なのですが
今世界は平和だと思いますか
して平和とは言えないなぁと思った方は
いつか世界が平和になると思いますか
私の答えを結論から言うと世界は平和にできると思っています
しかも皆さんがやりたいことを本気で追求することでそれは成し遂げられると思ってい
ます
今日はその理由をお話しします
私の生まれ育った広島県では
73年前の8月6日し原子爆弾が投下されました
私のおじいちゃんは当時5歳で実家が一緒だったのです
爆心地からは50キロ以上も離れて山の中だったんですけど
翌日には皮膚の焼けた大勢の人が歩いてやってきたそうです
8月6日
夏休み真っ只中にあたりその日
広島県内の小学生は特例で学校に登校します
その日は黙とうし
半日かけて平和や平和に関する聞きやビデオ見たり
分実際にそのうちにオウムいたりして併用について考えます
私はそのような平和教育というものを受けて育ってきました
例えば中学校3年生のときです
その日はえんそくで瀬戸内海に浮かぶ小さな島多くの島という島に行きました
島中にはかわいらしいウサギがのんびりと生息し耳を澄ますとさざ波の音が聞こえる
穏やかな島です
休日には多くの観光客が訪れます
しかし
その下は実は戦時中志津から抹消されていました
当時国際法で禁止とされていた
化学兵器毒ガスが秘密裏に製造されていたからです
今でも当時の建物が残されています
近隣の農民や勤労学生6500人ほどが強制的に働かされていました
多くが16し小さいほどの未成年だったと聞きます
島で見聞きしたことは完全に口外禁止とされ
従事者はその秘密が明るみになって差別を受けることを恐れながら暮らしていました
そのためその事実が公になったのはなんと戦後40年も経ってからのことだったんです
戦争が終わって不要となった化学兵器や毒ガスは海底やつ中に本気されて
所属処理はされたものの完全ではなかったためいまだに海底から高濃度の猛毒ヒ素検出
されるという現場まであります
そんなことを15歳の中学校3年生と教わったんです
そして幼いながらに
平和や未来について考えてきましたーー
その経験がとても貴重だったんだということを私は上京してきてから気づきました
そして同時にこのような疑問を抱いたんです
平和教育で本当に世界は平和になるのでしょうか
その事実はまだわからないと今後の未来の期待を込めて動かしておきます
しかし本当に平和教育で社会が絶対に平和になると言えるのであればその上位9は
すべての人に触れて欲しいものだと自信を持って言えます
しかし
じゃあ平和教育で社会は絶対に平和になると自信を断言できないのも事実なんです
というのも私は現在大学を休学しながら
広島の若者と一緒に組織をつくっています
それは彼らの可能性に大きなは彼らの未来に大きな可能性を感じたからです
そして私は気になって彼らに聞くんです
将来がどう考えているのと
すると彼はこう答えました
自信を
自信を持って自分の将来を語れる環境もないし
自分に自信もないんだ
なんとなくてこのまま親の進めるような企業に就職してしまうのだろうか
そしてこうも言いました
自分の将来を誰にも否定されずに語りたい
私はそれを聞いて社会に出る前に自分の理想の
ているニス自分の理想とする人や仲間に出会える環境があったらいいのになぁと思って
広島未来会議というイベントを開催しました
そこにはおもしろいと思った生き方をしている人を集めて
気軽に交流できる機会を作りました
例えば公立学校の先生を止めて村づくりを始めた人や大手企業に勤めながらも自分に
しかできないことを実現しようと会社を立ち上げた人など様々な人に広島まで来て
もらいました
そこで
自分の今まで常識だと思っていた範囲の中で常識だと思っていた政界の外で生きている
人を知ることで彼らは自分の未来を認めてほしいという欲求で止まっていた人たちも
自分で実現できるにはどうすればいいだろうかと考え始め
一歩を踏み出したんです
私はその過程を見て通る
師匠思い出せました
それは心理学者マズローの唱えた欲求段階説です
人間の欲求はこのように5段階ないさあ6段階に分かれていると称えられた雪です
生存安全所属承認欲求という4つの欠乏欲求と自己実現欲求
そしてさらにはその上の自己超越欲求っていう2つの成長欲求から成り立つものです
最初に
自分の語る将来を否定されず否定されることなく語りたい認めてほしいと言っていた彼
らは4段目の承認欲求に属していました
しかしそんな彼らも自分の身近に
自分のやりたいことに挑戦し課題ている人の姿を見ることで自分にもそれを実現するに
はどうすればいいだろうか
自分ももっと成長したいと一歩を踏み出し始めましたよね
それは俺の5段目の自己実現欲求に移行していたと言えるんです
このように人間の欲求は結合欲求が満たされることで初めて
次のステージへと上がれることに暴れると言えます
心の器をコップに一つのコップに例えてみます
満たされていない状態だと乾きます
安定したい
愛情や商人がほしいという状態では誰かに与えることはできません
それらが満たされたときに初めて
誰かの役に立ちたい成長したいそして夢自分も夢を叶えたいという欲求がわくように
なるんです
その時に
自分がそれまで乗っていたレールのレールの中から一歩踏み出す勇気を持つことで
私たちは次のステージへと進めるんです
心が何を求めているのか耳を傾けてあげませんか
そして乱されたなと思ったら次への一歩を踏み出しませんか
私はそのそれこそが平和への鍵だと思ったんです
それは欲求のマネジメント
もっとわかりやすく言うと自分の心に素直に生きることだと思いました
麻生人や戦争する人は何も人を傷つけたくてそうしているわけではないんです
自分が本当に欲しいもの
自分の話を聞いて欲しい話があってそれでそれがうまく伝えられずに争っているだけな
んです
その欲求に自分が素直になり相手に伝えるだったり逆に相手の話し相手がよっ本当に
欲求として必要としているもの耳に引き入れるだったり
そしてお互いにときには頼りあって皮膚&テイクをすることで
人は問題を解決できると思うんです
そう
平和への鍵は欲求のマネジメント自分の心に素直になることです
ここで先ほどの
最初の質問最初の疑問
なぜ
平和教育で社会を平和にできると断言できないのか
そしてなぜ
平和について幼い時から考え関心を持ってきた若者でも未来に踏みとどまってしまって
いるのか
そしてなぜこんなに満たされていて安全で
物質的にも豊かなはずの日本でも今世界は平和ですかという問いに yes と答える
ことに躊躇してしまう時があるのか
その答えは
平和にしようっていうメッセージと個々人の欲求が結びついていないことだと思いまし
た
そして人間は自分の欲求に対しでしか
神のパワーを発揮できないんです
自己実現欲求も紛れもなく
欲求ですよね
私はそれを自分らしさで誰かを幸せにできることと解釈していますが
自分の双雷に夢
そして最高級に幸せと感じる価値観だったり
志ともいえるそれは紛れもなく欲求でありあるしのエゴなんです
そして人間の無意識には切れてしまう欲求というものは私たちの想像を遥かに超える
パワーを持っています
それは本当に講師の欲求として
社会を平和にしたいと思う人手
身近が身近の周りがあふれとならばそれは世界を平和にせよとプログラムされた
ロボットよりも確実に成し遂げてしまうだろうと思っています
しっかりと根を張った志を育てるには十分な土壌が必要です
もちろん海の欲求は満たされている必要があります
しかし
現在の教育はまだしっかりと根が張っていない状態に
知識や情報やスキルといったものといったシャワーを表面的に浴びせているだけのよう
に思えてしまうんです
これは平和教育に限った話ではありません
土台どんなどんな
その人の土壌をどんな成分が構成しているのか
その人はどんな環境で花を咲かせることが得意なのか
何が好きで何が嫌いなのか
学校や社会はそのようなことを
尊重しないままに押し付けてしまっているだけだったのではないでしょうか
平和と一言に言っても
一人一人が理想と描く世界は違うはずです
公教育としての平和教育はそれらをあなたにとっての理想の世界は何ですかあなたに
とっての位相と描く将来は何ですかと言うというよりミクロな視点で追及すべきだった
と思うんです
その上でようやく知識や技術はその人を成長させたい方向へ成長させる風となるから
です
さて a
このようにしてじゃあ自分はどんな女を育てたいのかどんな方向に育ちたいいのかと
いう志の目をしっかりと根を張った状態で芽生えさしそれを実現させることができる
状態になったらどうなるでしょう
すなわち一人ひとりが自己実現欲求まで満たされた状態になるとどんな
世界へ人類はどんな境地へたどり着くのでしょうか
自分の欲求は全て満たされました
するとどうでしょう
誰かに与えることができると思いませんか
それが自己超越欲求すなわち
愛を与えることができる世界だと思うんです
止まるとどうでしょう
世界は平和になりませんか
最初にお聞きした
私は世界が平和にできると思うと答えた理由は
一人一人が自分のやりたいことを見つけそしてそれを実現するために成長しそれが
やがて社会に還元されるという子されるということがいえると思ったからです
つまり一人一人が自分のやりたい事を本気で追求することが結局誰かの幸せ
つのすなわち世界の平和につながっていると信じているからなんです
人類の栄養バランスや
衛生問題は随分と改善されました
技術はめまぐるしく発達し不満や不便はどんどんと改称されています
そして長寿国課題先進国とも呼ばれる
呼ばれ世界の先頭を走っている日本
被ばくや機材といった体験を共に手を取り合い
立ち上がってきた歴史を持つ日本
この国はまさに愛の次元へと世界を牽引していく
存在なのではないでしょうか
私もこの会場の皆さんもそのカギを握っています
だからお願いがあるんです
私から伝えたかったメッセージは
皆さんの魂の声を大切に育ててあげてください
そして自分がやりたいと思ったことをすごい追求して欲しいと思うんです
それこそが
世界を平和にする第一歩だからです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]